can you maybe um
this is a therapy session psychoanalyze
me for a second like for example i
really like the elder scrolls series
it's a role-playing game
uh skyrim for example why do i enjoy
so deeply just walking around that world
and then there's people and you could
talk to
and you can
just like it's an escape but you know my
my life is awesome i'm truly happy but i
also am happy with the
the music that's playing and the
mountains and
uh carrying around a sword and just that
i don't know what that is it's very
pleasant though to go there and i miss
it sometimes i think it's
wonderful
to love
artistic creations it's wonderful to
love
contact with other people it's wonderful
to love play and ongoing evolving
meaning and patterns with other people i
think it's uh it's a good thing
you know i um
i'm not i'm not like anti-tech and i'm
certainly not anti-digital tech i'm anti
as everybody knows by now i think the
you know
manipulative economy of social media is
making everybody nuts and all that so
i'm anti that stuff but the core of it
of course i worked for many many years
on trying to make that stuff happen
because i think it can be beautiful like
i
um i don't like why not
you know and and by the way
um there's a thing about humans which is
um
uh we're problematic any
any kind of social interaction with
other people is gonna have its problems
people are
political and tricky and like i love
classical music but when you actually go
to a classical music thing and it turns
out oh actually this is like a backroom
power deal kind of place and a big
status ritual as well and that's kind of
not as fun
that's part of the package and the thing
is it's always going to be there's
always going to be a mix of things
um
i i don't uh i don't think the search
for purity is going to get you anywhere
so i'm not worried about that i worry
about the really bad cases where we're
becoming where we're making ourselves
crazy or cruel enough that we might not
survive and i think you know the social
media criticism
rises to that level but i'm glad you
enjoyed it i think it's great
you